[Music]
yo it up this is Naish a minute college
teammate and close friend of pestering
Holmes I'm also really good friends with
Dominic cm brown take a few surgeon
knowin pets appreciation for Downton to
work with the fact that he should
sneakerhead in general how did he write
to team up with Don on 101 shoes for the
MVP himself
my personal trainer Nick got ahold of me
to make this custom sneaker you know I
talked to Nick a little bit about the
design and some ideas based on what I
think is cool and relevant I know his
favorite Adidas shoe was the EZ 750 and
I was like well the EZ 750 is kind of
tough I would really think that a easy
700 would be good for this shoe
specifically we only reuse the sole but
we also customize the sole to match the
color of the rest of the shoe I mean I
always find the Yeezy shoes to be a
little bit more intricate and
challenging to shoot there's a lot of
design detail that I feel like people
miss that actually makes it tougher to
recreate but I like challenges and I
thought this shoe would be perfect to do
someone's at the front door house with a
little housewarming gift some of the
details in the shoe that are specific to
Patrick are his logo on the tongue so
they got the Miren in there they got the
Y they got the black I had it like this
weighted Python I thought it would be a
good touch for him that I'm not oh three
that's the that's the biggest thing
that's wrong from Tyler Whitehouse
textures either sweet mad
no these are one of the cons she
certainly did these even has a little
logo up in here he's best at it so I'm
glad to have my own one-of-a-kind shoes
so this makes a different color whenever
a camera set up it's very reflective so
on the sides as well wash them so then
it kind of lights up that's really cool
from this to this like yeah
completely different how they're simple
enough to wear you can wear them I'm
wearing it everywhere bro that was the
goal I'm just a fan of people that
really go above and beyond and take
their craft to the next level so it's
pretty exciting to be able to see em
wear my shoes you might as well have the
best shoe creator in the world yeah I
can the shoe for best football player in
the world
and everything you need appreciate least
excess that's the most important thanks
hard to keep the secret of Nick coming
today I'm not a good secret keeper
got a river zapatero three
[Music]
[Applause]